From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life , and distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共电台发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
The voices that you are hearing is some children.
你听到的这些声音是一些孩子发出的。
What are they doing?
他们在做什么？
They are just walking. Nothing else.
他们只是在走路。没别的。
This week I talked to a Haitian journalist, Romuald Felix, over his cell phone as he recorded himself walking around one of the tent cities where some of the 1.3 million displaced Haitians are still living. This was a small tent city in a plaza in the Place Saint Pierre crammed with people.
这周我采访了一位海地记者罗穆亚尔德·费利克斯，当时他正用手机边走边录，拍摄圣皮埃尔广场一个难民帐篷营地。海地有130万人流离失所，这是其中一个小营地，挤满了人。
You can see, you know this music that you hear is a man who is putting a big speaker out and some people are dancing. And you can see a man is just sitting there doing nothing. He is just watching.
你可以看到，你知道，你听到的这些音乐是一个男人放出来的，他架起了一个大音箱，有些人正在跳舞。你也可以看到一个男人只是坐在那里，什么也没做。他只是在看着。
Four months after the earthquake, Romuald says that some people were working, selling fruit, charging cell phones for money on the street, but lots aren't. The rainy season-- which everyone has been dreading-- finally started in earnest last week. He was trapped in his office one day by water three feet deep. Camps get muddy. Water gets in the tents. People have trouble sleeping with it so wet.
地震发生四个月后，罗穆亚尔德说，有些人还在工作，卖水果，或者在街上靠给手机充电赚钱，但很多人并没有工作。每个人都担心的雨季上周终于真正开始了。有一天，他被困在办公室里，因为积水深达三英尺。营地变得泥泞不堪。水流进了帐篷。人们在这种潮湿的环境下很难入睡。
In this camp, people still have to bathe where everybody can see. There are only six toilets for a thousand people, or maybe it's a lot more than a thousand, so lots of people go in plastic bags. And in the six camps that Romuald visited this week, aid agencies had stopped giving out food.
在这个营地里，人们仍然必须在众目睽睽之下洗澡。一千人甚至更多的人共用仅有的六个厕所，所以很多人只能用塑料袋解决。在罗穆亚尔德本周访问的六个营地中，援助机构已经停止发放食物了。
[SPEAKING FRENCH] You hear them?
[法语] 你听见他们了吗？
[ROMUALD SPEAKING FRENCH WITH HAITIAN CHILDREN]
[罗穆亚尔德用法语与海地儿童交谈]
It was 5:00 at night. Romuald asked these four children if they'd eaten today.
当时是晚上5点。罗穆亚尔德问这四个孩子今天有没有吃东西。
[ROMUALD SPEAKING FRENCH WITH HAITIAN CHILDREN]
[罗穆亚尔德用法语与海地儿童交谈]
Two of them said, "I ate something today," and the others said, "No I haven't eaten anything."
其中两个说，“我今天吃了一点，”而另一些人说，“不，我什么都没吃。”
When I talked this week to Nan Buzard-- who runs relief operations in Haiti for the American Red Cross-- she was unsurprised to hear that people aren't getting food and services, with over 1,000 makeshift camps, there are a lot of gaps. She'd just returned from Haiti the day before we spoke and said that now that they're shifting from the immediate disaster relief to the rebuilding of the country, the decisions have gotten very complicated.
当我这周采访美国红十字会负责海地救灾工作的南·布扎德时，她对人们没得到食物和服务的消息并不感到惊讶，因为有超过1000个临时营地，存在很多缺口。我们交谈的前一天她刚从海地回来，她说，既然现在救灾重心正从紧急救援转向国家重建，决策变得非常复杂。
I know in Haiti already there are some evaluations where it's showing that local farmers don't feel like it's worth buying seed or bringing their crops into market, because people have had free food distributions.
我知道海地已经有一些评估显示，当地农民觉得购买种子或把农作物运到市场不划算，因为人们已经习惯了免费的食物分发。
And they're not going to buy from them.
所以他们不打算从农民那里买东西。
Yeah.
是的。
So when should relief agencies stop giving away free food or providing shelter? When does that become counterproductive? What should they do about something as basic as water?
那么援助机构应该在什么时候停止免费发放食物或提供住所呢？什么时候这会变得适得其反？对于水这种基本需求，他们又该怎么做？
Prior to the earthquake, 70% of the water in Port-au-Prince was sold out of water tanker trucks by small commercial firms. So do we use aid money to actually put those small, individual companies back in business so that they can then charge money for water? Do we try to support the government to actually create a water policy and plan, an infrastructure that provides a certain amount of water free, and then perhaps over that it's a cost to the government?
地震前，太子港70%的水是由小型商业公司的水罐车售卖的。那么我们应该用援助资金去帮助这些小公司恢复经营，让他们重新开始卖水吗？还是我们应该尝试支持政府建立水政策、规划和基础设施，提供一定量的免费水，超过部分再收费？
So that seems like an impossible choice. What are we doing?
这似乎是一个不可能的选择。我们到底在做什么？
We all-- we struggle. We all struggle.
我们都在——我们都在挣扎。我们都在挣扎。
Today on our radio show-- there's been this fantastic outpouring of money and goodwill from around the world. Nearly half of all American households have donated to Haiti, according to one survey. Haitians and foreigners have dedicated themselves to rebuilding the country. And now the question is, how exactly do you do that? Even with all this money and expertise, it's incredibly complicated. And today we join the people on the ground as they try to figure out what would be best. Next. Our show in three acts. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中——世界各地涌现出了巨大的金钱和善意。据一项调查显示，近一半的美国家庭为海地捐了款。海地人和外国人都致力于重建这个国家。现在的问题是，具体该怎么做？即使有这么多钱和专业知识，这也极其复杂。今天，我们将跟随实地的工作人员，看看他们如何寻找最佳方案。接下来，我们的节目分为三幕。请继续收听。
Act One, 10,000 Brainiacs. We're all used to the basics. Haiti is the poorest country in the western hemisphere, one of the 10 or so poorest countries on earth, with the special designation of being one of the few countries in the world that-- for decades-- has gotten poorer and poorer over time. This despite billions in foreign aid, despite the fact that even before the earthquake there were approximately 10,000 non-governmental organizations trying to do good in the country. Two of the reporters that you hear a lot on our show doing economic stories-- Adam Davidson and Chana Joffe-Walt-- have been trying to figure out how it is possible Haiti is still so poor despite all that. They've been traveling back and forth to the country following developments over the last few months and have this story.
第一幕：10,000个智囊。我们都习惯了基本事实：海地是西半球最贫穷的国家，也是全球十个最贫穷的国家之一，并有一个特殊的称号——几十年来，它是世界上为数不多越来越穷的国家之一。尽管有数十亿的外国援助，尽管地震前就有大约10,000个非政府组织试图在当地做好事。我们节目中常出现的两位经济报道记者——亚当·戴维森和查娜·乔夫-沃尔特——一直试图找出为什么在这一切之下，海地依然如此贫穷。过去几个月里，他们往返于海地，追踪事态发展，并带来了这个故事。
Here's something that happens a lot in Haiti. You meet someone poor and they tell you the sad reality of their life, some challenge they face every day that keeps them poor. You hear the details and you just can't believe the magnitude of the problem, not because it's big and complicated, because it is so, so small.
在海地，经常会发生这样的事。你见到一个穷人，他们会告诉你生活的艰辛，告诉你每天面临的某种让他们保持贫困的挑战。你听着细节，却无法相信问题的严重性，不是因为问题很大很复杂，而是因为它太小太小了。
For example, we met a farmer at this farm, a dusty, patchy field, nothing valuable growing on it, except in the corner, mangoes.
例如，我们在一个农场见到了一位农民，那是一块布满灰尘、零零碎碎的田地，除了角落里的芒果树，没种什么有价值的东西。
How many trees do you have?
你有多少棵树？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
He has two.
他有两棵。
The farmer tells us, two trees is barely enough to make a living. She wants more trees. She has the space for 100 trees. She has the time to tend them, but she has no water. Mango trees need water.
这位农民告诉我们，两棵树勉强够糊口。她想要更多的树。她有种100棵树的空间，也有时间照料，但她没有水。芒果树需要水。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
But then we walk across the field. And right at the far end of it is this roaring river. Right there. Right next to her farm.
但当我们走过那片田地时，尽头就是那条奔腾的河流。就在那里。就在她农场旁边。
Why is water a problem if you have water right here?
如果旁边就有水，为什么水还是个问题呢？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
We talked about this question for a long time. It was really confusing. It just did not make sense to us that she couldn't come up with some way to get water from the river right next to her farm onto her farm.
我们讨论了很久这个问题。这真的很令人困惑。我们实在无法理解她为什么不能想办法把河里的水引到田里。
At one point I thought, is she lying to us? Why would she lie? Is she just lazy? Does she not have a bucket? So many questions.
有一刻我心想，她在撒谎吗？她为什么要撒谎？她只是懒吗？她没有桶吗？有太多的疑问了。
How do you get water now?
你现在怎么取水？
Why don't you have enough water to water these trees?
为什么你没有足够的水来浇这些树？
Dozens of questions and a consultation with the local mayor--
几十个问题，还有与当地市长的咨询——
Who happens to be a self-proclaimed, amateur, mango specialist.
他恰好是个自封的、业余的芒果专家。
Yes, that all ultimately reveals a wildly undramatic truth. She needs a canal, some guys with shovels to dig a trench, some concrete to protect it.
没错，最终这一切揭示了一个毫不戏剧化的事实：她需要一条运河，几个拿铲子的家伙挖条沟，再用点混凝土保护一下。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
The world's simplest, shortest canal. It's a little tricky. The water needs to sit in a particular way around the roots of the mango tree, so you need some control over the water. But it's not that tricky. It's technology the Sumerians probably took for granted 5,000 years ago. It would cost-- at most-- $2,000. And if she gets a canal, she and her family go from being some of the poorest people on earth to much better off.
世界上最简单、最短的运河。这有点讲究。水需要以特定的方式停留在芒果树根部周围，所以你需要控制水流。但这并不复杂。这大概是5000年前苏美尔人就已经掌握的技术。它最多只需要2000美元。如果她有了运河，她和她的家人就能从世界上最贫穷的人变得好过得多。
This is what kept striking us in Haiti, just a little upfront investment and people could be living so much better. And with 10,000 organizations in the country doing nothing but trying to make people's lives better-- 10,000 organizations whose mission is to do things like building canals-- how come the average Haitian makes half as much as they did 50 years ago? How come life wasn't improving even before the earthquake?
这就是在海地不断震撼我们的事实，只需一点前期投资，人们就能过得好得多。而当地有10,000个组织，专门致力于让人们生活得更好——这10,000个组织的使命就是做修建运河之类的事情——为什么普通海地人现在的收入只有50年前的一半？为什么地震前生活甚至没有改善？
Well, to answer that, we have to leave the farm for a couple minutes-- we will be back-- and meet a businessman name Jean-Maurice Buteau and watch him try to work with one of those non-governmental organizations-- NGOs-- to solve one problem for Haitian farmers. The story begins two years ago.
好吧，为了回答这个问题，我们得先离开农场几分钟——我们还会回来的——去见一位叫让-莫里斯·布托的商人，看看他如何尝试与其中一个非政府组织合作，为海地农民解决问题。故事始于两年前。
I heard about Jean-Maurice weeks before we met him. We'd been going around Port-au-Prince asking, what are the main industries? Who are the main players? And there aren't a lot of big businessmen in Haiti. The ones that do exist all know each other. They're unusual Haitians in almost every way. They tend to have light skin, they drive cars, have college degrees, speak English. Jean-Maurice though, he's the only one known by a special name.
在见到让-莫里斯的前几周，我就听说过他了。我们当时在太子港到处问，主要产业是什么？主要人物是谁？海地没有多少大商人。现有的那些人彼此都认识。他们在各方面都是不同寻常的海地人。他们皮肤往往较浅，开着汽车，有大学学位，讲英语。不过，让-莫里斯是唯一一个被称为特殊名字的人。
First of all, what do you sell specifically?
首先，你具体卖什么？
Well, we export mangoes. Mango is the number one agricultural export from Haiti.
我们出口芒果。芒果是海地第一大农产品出口。
Are you Mr. Mango?
你是“芒果先生”吗？
That's what they call me. Just people started calling me like that.
他们就是这么叫我的。只是人们开始那样叫我了。
We actually found out later that most people call Jean-Maurice "Mango Man," not Mr. Mango. And Mango Man is one of the biggest mango exporters in Haiti.
后来我们发现，大多数人叫让-莫里斯“芒果男”，而不是“芒果先生”。而“芒果男”是海地最大的芒果出口商之一。
Mango Man has a very consistent look. Most any day, any context, he's in a white linen button-down, sunglasses with the strap around the back of his head, and a Bluetooth headset. He talks on the Bluetooth a lot, usually while ramming his Jeep through Port-au-Prince's potholes, even while he's talking to you. It's Bluetooth, you, Bluetooth, you, seamless, and confusing if you're you.
“芒果男”的形象非常固定。几乎每天，在任何场合，他都穿着白色亚麻衬衫，戴着后面有带子的墨镜，戴着蓝牙耳机。他经常用蓝牙说话，通常是在他的吉普车撞过太子港的坑洼路面时，甚至是在跟你说话的时候。蓝牙、你、蓝牙、你，无缝连接，如果你是他交谈的对象，会觉得很困惑。
And Mango Man has a problem. Fruit wholesalers in New York and Miami want to buy a lot of his mangoes. But he can't get enough to meet the demand--
而且“芒果男”有一个问题。纽约和迈阿密的果品批发商想买很多他的芒果。但他无法获得足够的产量来满足需求——
Which is strange, because Haiti actually grows enough mangoes to send to all of the Floridians and New Yorkers who want them. But most of those mangoes aren't grown on big farms. They're grown by individual farmers with just two or three mango trees each. And every season, those farmers pick the mangoes and then store them in a pile outside their houses, or under their beds, where they wait until some middle man-- usually a local guy with a donkey-- comes by and buys them.
这很奇怪，因为海地实际上种植的芒果足够供应所有想要的佛罗里达人和纽约人。但这些芒果大多不是在大农场种植的，而是由个体农民种植的，每家只有两三棵芒果树。每个季节，农民们摘下芒果，然后堆在房子外面或床下，等待中间人——通常是骑着驴的当地人——过来收购。
Americans-- as it turns out-- don't like mangoes that have sat under Haitian beds. Those usually have bruises on them, marks. And so, two years ago-- long before the earthquake-- Jean-Maurice came up with a solution, a business concept that would double his revenue.
事实证明，美国人不喜欢放在海地床下的芒果。那些芒果通常有淤伤和痕迹。所以，两年前——远在地震前——让-莫里斯想出了一个解决方案，一个能使他收入翻倍的商业概念。
The concept is-- the simplest thing is cleaning the fruit, transporting it in a plastic crate, to a facility that is not exposed to the sun.
这个概念最简单的一点就是清洁水果，用塑料板条箱运输，放到一个不暴露在阳光下的设施中。
So basically, you lose a huge amount of your crop because people don't use plastic containers?
所以基本上，是因为人们不使用塑料容器，你才损失了大量的农作物？
And they don't clean the fruit and they don't transport it correctly. The amount of damage we witness-- over 40% to 50% of our production in all sectors-- lost between the field and the table.
而且他们不清洁水果，也没有正确运输。我们目睹的损害程度——所有行业中40%到50%的产量——都在从田间到餐桌的过程中流失了。
So you are on a mission to get plastic crates to mango farmers.
所以你的使命是给芒果农提供塑料箱。
I mean, it's very self-serving because I'm going to have more product. I mean, I'm not a philanthropist. I'm doing this because I need the product.
我的意思是，这非常自私，因为我会得到更多的产品。我不是慈善家。我这么做是因为我需要产品。
So back two years ago, before the earthquake, the first thing Jean-Maurice did was he took a bunch of crates, drove 45 minutes out of town to a small mango growing village called Casale. And he went to each house one by one. He'd find the mango farmers on some tiny dirt road. He'd get out of his jeep and hand out his crates. Unfortunately, that with an enormous failure.
回到两年前，地震之前，让-莫里斯做的第一件事是拿了一堆箱子，开车45分钟出城，去了一个叫卡萨莱的小芒果村。他挨家挨户地走。他在土路上找到芒果农。他跳下吉普车，发他的箱子。不幸的是，那次行动彻底失败了。
Well, first they used them as chairs. They would sit on them. They would carry too heavy stuff on it. They were being used for different things that is appropriate for them, in school as bookshelves. Right?
好吧，首先他们把箱子当椅子坐。他们坐在上面。他们还用箱子搬运太重的东西。箱子被用于不恰当的用途，在学校里当书架。对吧？
And they got lost.
而且它们丢了。
Well, a lot of them got broken.
好吧，很多都坏了。
When you talk to Jean-Maurice about the crate problem, it seems confusing why this would ever be a problem in the first place. Just tell the farmers, hey, if you pack your mangoes in these crates, everyone will make twice as much money. And then you actually go to the farms and you meet the farmers and you completely get it. Because you meet someone like [? Jealin ?] [? Jermouse ?].
当你和让-莫里斯谈论箱子问题时，起初觉得这为什么会成为问题很令人费解。只要告诉农民，嘿，如果你把芒果装在这些箱子里，大家收入都能翻倍。然后当你真正去到农场见到农民，你就完全明白了。因为你见到了像[杰琳·杰穆斯]这样的人。
[? Jealin ?] is that mango farmer from the beginning, the one who needs a canal. And she lives in Casale where Jean-Maurice went and handed out his crates. She didn't know who he was. In fact, it's unclear that [? Jealin ?] even knew that her mangoes are being sent to America.
[杰琳]就是最开始提到的那个芒果农，那个需要运河的人。她住在卡萨莱，也就是让-莫里斯去发箱子的地方。她不知道他是谁。事实上，不清楚[杰琳]甚至知不知道她的芒果正被运往美国。
Here's what she did know. Her trees earned her around $600 a year, $2 a day. And in Haiti, $2 a day gets you a house made out of cinder block and metal sheets with a dirt floor on a dirt road. She can only afford to send one of her two kids to school. She chose the younger one. She has no electricity, no running water, no doctor, which makes [? Jealin ?] precisely the average Haitian.
这是她知道的：她的树一年赚600美元，每天2美元。在海地，每天2美元能让你住上用煤渣砖和金属板盖的房子，里面是泥地，外面是土路。她只能负担得起送两个孩子中的一个上学。她选择了小的那个。她没有电，没有自来水，没有医生，这使得[杰琳]恰好就是海地人的缩影。
Average in every way but one.
除了一个方面，她在各方面都很普通。
[JEALIN'S LAUGHTER]
[杰琳的笑声]
It's that laugh. She starts every single sentence with it.
那就是她的笑声。她说的每一句话开头都有它。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
People in the neighborhood will say I love to laugh, I love to joke.
邻居们会说我爱笑，爱开玩笑。
The loudest, laughing mom with the two most sullen, withdrawn teenagers in all of Haiti.
这位最大声、最爱笑的母亲，带着海地最阴沉、最孤僻的两个青少年。
I tried and tried. And here are the only few words I managed to extract from her oldest daughter. She's telling me about her sister's school.
我试了又试。这是我从她大女儿那里提取出来的仅有的几个词。她在告诉我关于她妹妹学校的事。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
Again, daughter.
又是女儿。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
Mother.
母亲。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[? Jealin ?] has no car, no bike, no irrigation, no mattress. So for some white guy from Port-au-Prince-- that's how she sees Jean-Maurice-- for him to show up at Jealin's in his jeep and start handing out crates, she's not going to say, oh OK, this is a tool to increase my earning capacity. [? Jealin ?] doesn't mind bruises on her mangoes. She doesn't know anyone who does. She has no way of even conceptualizing a picky, American consumer. If Jean-Maurice is at about the level of a US exporter 50 years ago, [? Jealin ?] is living in the 1700s, well, with a cell phone.
[杰琳]没有车，没有自行车，没有灌溉，没有床垫。所以对于一个来自太子港的白人——她是这么看让-莫里斯的——他开着吉普车出现，开始发放箱子，她不会说，哦好的，这是一个增加我收入能力的工具。 [杰琳]不在乎她的芒果是否有淤伤。她不认识任何在乎的人。她甚至无法想象挑剔的美国消费者。如果让-莫里斯的水平相当于50年前的美国出口商，那么[杰琳]就像生活在1700年代——哦，只不过带了一部手机。
Jean-Maurice realized he was going to need an intermediary, someone who could spend the time to train the farmers how to use the crates, to train them why they should want to use the crates. Basically, someone who can help the farmers accommodate the needs of people living in the 21st century, people these farmers have never met before and can't imagine.
让-莫里斯意识到他需要一个中间人，一个能花时间培训农民如何使用箱子，告诉他们为什么应该使用箱子的人。基本上，是一个能帮助农民适应21世纪人们需求的人，这些人是农民从未见过、也无法想象的。
And here is where Jean-Maurice hooked up with one of those 10,000 NGOs in Haiti-- non-governmental organizations. Lots of them specialize in training small farmers in agricultural techniques. In fact, many are focused specifically on mangoes, because study after study shows that mangoes are one of the greatest areas of potential growth for Haiti. So there's lots of money and there's lots of specialists ready to help those mango farmers. And here is where we begin to see what those 10,000 organizations are up against.
在这里，让-莫里斯联系上了海地那10,000个非政府组织中的一个。许多组织专门培训小农户掌握农业技术。事实上，许多组织专门针对芒果，因为一项又一项研究表明，芒果是海地最具增长潜力的领域之一。所以有很多资金和专家准备帮助那些芒果农。在这里，我们开始看到那10,000个组织所面临的困境。
Now Jean-Maurice-- like a surprising number of Haitians-- does not like those NGOs. He says-- and we heard this all the time in Haiti-- those NGOs have been helping for 50 years. And every year, Haiti is poorer and the NGOs are richer.
现在让-莫里斯——像许多海地人一样——不喜欢这些非政府组织。他说——我们在海地一直听到这种说法——这些非政府组织已经帮助了50年。而每年，海地都更穷，非政府组织却更富。
Well, we are working-- it's the first time I'm working with some NGOs. I've stayed away from them for the longest time, because sometimes I realized that they were causing more damage than good. But throughout the years, I've identified certain ones that seem to want to do some things.
好吧，我们正在合作——这是我第一次与一些非政府组织合作。我尽量避开他们很久了，因为有时我意识到他们造成的破坏大于益处。但在多年里，我确定了一些看起来确实想做点事情的组织。
The one he likes most is called MarChE. Well, it was actually this guy he liked the most, one of the staff named Pierre Brunache. Jean-Maurice liked that Pierre grew up in Haiti, even though Pierre lives in D.C. now. So Mango Man calls Pierre and says, hey, I can't get these mango farmers to use plastic crates. You're the expert. Can you help me?
他最喜欢的是一个叫MarChE的组织。其实他最喜欢的是其中一个叫皮埃尔·布鲁纳什的员工。让-莫里斯喜欢皮埃尔在海地长大这一点，尽管皮埃尔现在住在华盛顿。“芒果男”打电话给皮埃尔说，嘿，我无法让这些农民用塑料箱。你是专家。你能帮我吗？
And Pierre says--
皮埃尔说——
I didn't think it was difficult at all.
我一点都不觉得困难。
Jean-Maurice thought, great.
让-莫里斯心想，太好了。
And then Pierre went on.
然后皮埃尔继续说。
It's just a matter of getting the land, provide the technical assistance. I never thought it was something difficult.
这只是获得土地、提供技术援助的问题。我从没觉得有什么困难。
This is where Jean-Maurice gets nervous. Getting land? Technical assistance?
这时让-莫里斯开始紧张了。获得土地？技术援助？
Pierre explained. You can't just hand out crates to thousands of dispersed farmers. You need a central place with just a simple structure. Picture a carport, a quarter acre of land, with a hose. Farmers will bring their mangoes, learn how to pack the crates correctly, how to wash the mangoes. Pierre says, we have some rules about this because we've done this in other places. We've seen what works and what doesn't. And when you team up with an NGO, you have to follow their rules. So, if Mango Man wants crates, he has to find a farmer with some land that they can build the mango carport on.
皮埃尔解释说。你不能只是把箱子发给成千上万分散的农民。你需要一个中心场所，只需一个简单的结构。想象一个车棚，四分之一英亩的土地，带一根水管。农民们会把芒果带来，学习如何正确装箱，如何清洗芒果。皮埃尔说，我们对此有一些规则，因为我们在其他地方这样做过。我们看到了什么有效，什么无效。当你与非政府组织合作时，必须遵循他们的规则。所以，如果“芒果男”想要箱子，他必须找到一个拥有土地的农民，在那里建芒果车棚。
To which Jean-Maurice replied, have you ever met a Haitian farmer?
对此，让-莫里斯回答说，你见过海地农民吗？
Just imagine. You are a small farmer and you own that piece of land. That's all you have.
试想一下。你是一个小农户，你拥有那一小块土地。那就是你的全部所有。
To which Pierre replied, and there's one other rule. The farmer can't own the land the center will be on. They have to donate it. The center will become the economic powerhouse of the community, so you need a neutral place. You can't let one family own it. It has to become a cooperative owned by all of the farmers.
皮埃尔回答说，还有一条规则。农民不能拥有中心所在的土地。他们必须捐赠出来。中心将成为社区的经济引擎，所以你需要一个中立的地方。你不能让一个家庭拥有它。它必须成为所有农民拥有的合作社。
And so, Jean-Maurice began his campaign to convince some poor farmer to give up some of his precious land. He called someone he knew in Casale to find out who might have some land. The guy talked to his cousin, [? Jealin, ?] the one with the laugh. [? Jealin's ?] family has a very nice piece of land in a great spot, near the road and near the mango farms. Now, this is where the mission to get some mango farmers a few plastic crates goes from involved to complicated. Because the thing is, the land was passed down from a great-great-grandfather. Maybe a great-great-great-grandfather, nobody remembers exactly. The point is, a whole lot of cousins have equal claim to the land.
于是，让-莫里斯开始了劝说农民放弃珍贵土地的运动。他给卡萨莱认识的人打了电话，打听谁可能有土地。那个人跟他的表亲[杰琳]谈了，就是那个爱笑的女人。[杰琳]家在很好的位置有一块非常好的土地，靠近公路和芒果园。现在，这正是让芒果农获得几个塑料箱的使命变得复杂的地方。因为那块地是曾曾祖父传下来的。也许是曾曾曾祖父，没人记得确切。重点是，一大堆堂表亲对这块地都有平等的权利。
[? Jealin ?] called a meeting, gathered her family together to decide whether or not they wanted to donate the land.
[杰琳]召开了会议，召集了她的家人，决定是否捐赠这块土地。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
Where we met, there's a big tree. We have a lot of shadow. It's cool there. Then we sit down on some chairs around the tree.
我们见面的地方有一棵大树。我们有很多树荫。那里很凉快。然后我们坐在树下的椅子上。
How many people?
多少人？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
60 or 80 people all sat under this tamarind tree? Really?
60或80人全都坐在那棵罗望子树下？真的吗？
A big, big tree.
一棵很大很大的树。
Everyone, all the cousins started asking questions.
每个人，所有的表亲都开始提问。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
Who is this white guy from the capital?
这个从首都来的白人是谁？
Why doesn't he buy our land?
为什么他不买我们的土地？
What if he never does anything with it?
如果他从不用这块地怎么办？
We're going to give away all our land? What will we leave for our children?
我们要捐掉所有的土地吗？我们要留给孩子们什么？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
Everyone, all the 60, must agree. And then nine of them will sign for everyone.
每个人，这60个人，必须都同意。然后九个人签字代表所有人。
There were factions, big disagreements. For a while, Jealin's brother was a holdout. So were the loud cousins, who nobody likes, who left town a while ago but came back when they heard someone was interested in the land.
有派系，有巨大的分歧。有一段时间，杰琳的哥哥一直在阻挠。还有那些爱大声嚷嚷的表亲，没人喜欢他们，他们早些年离开了镇子，但听说有人对这块地感兴趣就回来了。
So many meetings under that tamarind tree. Jean-Maurice drove in for many of them.
在那棵罗望子树下开了好多会。让-莫里斯为了很多会议开了车过来。
It took months. It took months. I didn't go everyday. We held meetings here. I went there. And their family came here, now they're doing it with the land.
花了几个月。花了几个月。我不是每天都去。我们在这里开会。我去了那里。他们的家人来了这里，现在他们正在处理土地的问题。
So, we've got the land. We can get those crates here. Training. Those mangoes will be beautiful. The farmers will start earning twice as much, so will Jean-Maurice. He calls the NGO and says, all right guys, you can start building the center.
所以，我们拿到了土地。我们可以把那些箱子运过来。培训。那些芒果会很漂亮。农民的收入会翻倍，让-莫里斯也是。他打电话给非政府组织说，好了伙计们，你们可以开始建中心了。
The NGO says, great, we just need to see a copy of the deed.
非政府组织说，太好了，我们只需要看一眼地契。
The deed. So, Jean-Maurice goes back to the mango farmer with a quick, simple request.
地契。于是，让-莫里斯带着一个简单快捷的请求回到农民那里。
The family had acquired the land from somebody else. They never did the papers, but they had their understanding. So these papers first had to be transferred from the original owner to this family.
这家人从别人那里获得了土地。他们从未办手续，但有他们的共识。所以这些文件必须先从原始主人转给这个家庭。
Nobody knew who the original owner was, who sold the land to Jealin's great-great-grandfather.
没人知道原始主人是谁，谁把土地卖给了杰琳的曾曾祖父。
Or great-great-great-grandfather.
或者曾曾曾祖父。
Right. Nobody knew who had the deed now. But finally, [? Jealin's ?] brother remembered, wait, there was that uncle who always kept papers, the guy who left Haiti a while ago.
对。没人知道谁现在有地契。但最终，[杰琳]的哥哥记起来，等等，那个叔叔一直保留着文件，就是那个早些年离开海地的家伙。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
The person who had the paper is in New York?
有文件的人在纽约？
New York.
纽约。
How did you get the paper from him?
你是怎么从他那里拿到文件的？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
Someone who this person-- who is living in New York-- trusts, came with the paper.
那个住纽约的人信任的一个人，带着文件来了。
The brother tells me, that guy sent the paper from his basement in New York with someone he trusts to Haiti. So after weeks and weeks of waiting, they get the paper. But it turns out, to transfer a deed in Haiti involves, literally, hundreds of steps and hundreds of dollars. Transfer of land deed was not in the budget, and if there's one rule every NGO sticks to it's, you do not change the budget.
哥哥告诉我，那家伙从他在纽约的地下室，让人带着文件传给了海地信任的人。所以经过几周的等待，他们拿到了文件。但事实证明，在海地转让地契，从字面上看涉及数百个步骤和数百美元。转让土地地契不在预算之内，而如果有一个非政府组织坚持的规则，那就是：你不能更改预算。
This is where Jean-Maurice loses it.
这时让-莫里斯爆发了。
It has to go through this process, it had to go through this process, we had to put it in the budget. I said, well, we had to put it in the budget, but you know, there are sometimes things that occur that-- you know, I'm not God. I don't know every little detail of it. It's like, Hilary Clinton has to approve it at the State Department.
必须经过这个流程，必须经过这个流程，我们不得不把它放入预算。我说，好吧，我们不得不把它放入预算，但你知道，有时会发生一些事情——你知道，我不是上帝。我不知道它的每一个小细节。就像，希拉里·克林顿必须在国务院批准它一样。
Can I just remind everyone, we're talking about getting some farmers a few plastic crates? Crates that they want, that Mango Man wants to just give them, that the NGO wants them to have. But to get those crates to the village of Casale, 60 farmers had to donate some precious land. And they did it. Mango Man had to trust an NGO. And he did it. MarChE-- the NGO-- had to be flexible and pay for something that wasn't in the budget. And they did it. Together, all these people had to overcome more than a century of legal confusion, and they did it.
我能提醒大家吗？我们谈论的只是给一些农民几个塑料箱子？他们想要的箱子，芒果男只想送给他们的箱子，非政府组织也想让他们拥有的箱子。但为了把箱子运到卡萨莱村，60个农民必须捐出宝贵的土地。他们做到了。“芒果男”必须信任一个非政府组织。他也做到了。MarChE——那个非政府组织——必须灵活处理并支付预算外的东西。他们也做到了。所有人共同克服了一个多世纪的法律混乱，他们做到了。
Success. They get to the final, last step. December, 2009, a year and a half after they began. [? Jealin ?] and the other farmers form into a cooperative that would own and operate the crate center. They did that. They took all the paperwork, that very final document one last time into Port-au-Prince and delivered it to the government. This all happened at the very end of last year. And then on January 12 came the earthquake.
成功了。他们走到了最后一步。2009年12月，距离开始一年半后。[杰琳]和其他农民组成了一个合作社，将拥有并经营这个箱子中心。他们做到了。他们把所有的文件，那份最后的文件，又一次带到太子港，递交给了政府。这一切发生在去年年底。然后1月12日地震发生了。
The document that recognizes them is at the Ministry of Social Affairs. The Ministry of Social Affairs has been flattened like a pancake. Those certain documents are in the pile of rubble at the ministry, under the rubble.
认可他们的文件在社会事务部。社会事务部已经被夷为平地。那些文件在部门的废墟堆里，被埋在废墟下。
It was several weeks before Jean-Maurice could even bring himself to go back to Casale to visit the farmers. It wasn't clear if the earthquake destroyed the crates project entirely, or just set it back months, maybe years.
过了几个星期，让-莫里斯才敢回卡萨莱去探望农民。不清楚地震是彻底毁了箱子项目，还是只是拖延了几个月，甚至几年。
But as survivors started to think about their future, they started asking this question we'd hear every now and then-- usually after someone apologized for even thinking it. Was the earthquake the best thing that could've ever happened to Haiti?
但当幸存者开始思考他们的未来时，他们开始问这个问题，我们偶尔会听到——通常是在有人为自己有这种想法道歉之后。地震是海地可能发生的最棒的事吗？
The argument goes like this, the world is now focused on Haiti like never before. There's lots of money coming in. Before this, you had those 10,000 NGOs working independently on little projects, making slow progress, maybe, if at all. But what if now there is an opportunity to take all the attention, all the money, and work together like never before? What if this is the shot-- instead of solving one small problem at a time-- to address all the country's problems all at once.
论点是这样的：世界现在以前所未有的程度关注海地。有很多钱涌进来。在此之前，有那10,000个非政府组织独立开展小项目，取得缓慢的进展，如果有的话。但如果现在有机会利用所有的关注和资金，齐心协力呢？如果这是一个机会——不是一次解决一个问题，而是同时解决这个国家的所有问题呢？
Think about [? Jealin ?] and her mangoes. Her problems go way beyond those plastic crates. Remember, she needs a canal. And while we're at it, she needs a road. Once her mangoes get on the truck, they go down this crazy, choppy dirt road. In the rainy season, sometimes the road isn't even there. She really needs a paved road.
想想[杰琳]和她的芒果。她的问题远不止那几个塑料箱。记住，她需要一条运河。而且顺便说一下，她需要一条路。一旦她的芒果上了卡车，它们就得走过这条疯狂、颠簸的土路。雨季时，路甚至不存在。她真的需要一条铺好的路。
But then, if there's a lot more trucks carrying a lot more mangoes, the Haitian port can't handle that. Haiti's main seaport is really old. And they'd need to buy new equipment, which means a better banking system to give loans and more professional folks to operate things--
但如果装载更多芒果的卡车更多了，海地的港口就承受不了了。海地的主要海港真的很旧。他们需要购买新设备，这意味着需要更好的银行系统来发放贷款，需要更专业的人员来运作事物——
Which means better education to train those professional folks, and while we're at it, health, hospitals. [? Jealin's ?] brother can't help her on the farm because he's really sick. She thinks he has malaria. Thinks. She doesn't know because there's no doctor around to ask.
这意味着更好的教育来培养那些专业人员，顺便说一下，还有健康，医院。[杰琳]的哥哥不能在农场帮她，因为他病得很重。她认为他得了疟疾。认为。她不知道，因为没有医生可以询问。
If all that seems like a lot for the world to take on, seriously, we went to the place where this is truly the ambition.
如果所有这一切看起来太难了，说真的，我们去了真正有这种抱负的地方。
We're in a conference room in a new hotel on a hill outside Port-au-Prince where experts from all over the world are sitting around foldable tables and trying to figure out how to do every one of those things and more. They're trying to figure out how much it would cost to address all of Haiti's problems at once.
我们在太子港外山上一家新酒店的会议室里，来自世界各地的专家坐在折叠桌旁，试图弄清楚如何做到每一件事。他们试图算出同时解决海地所有问题需要多少钱。
Experts are here from the U.N., the World Bank, from all over the world, doing the thing experts do, staring at Excel spreadsheets and writing assessments. And they're all in these tables divided into groups. There's education, water, infrastructure.
专家们来自联合国、世界银行，来自世界各地，做着专家做的事，盯着Excel电子表格，写着评估报告。他们都被分在这些桌子旁。有教育、水、基础设施。
And Adam, you and I go table to table asking, what are you going to do for [? Jealin? ?] And everyone has really long, in depth answers. Infrastructure.
亚当，你和我一张桌子一张桌子地问，你们要为[杰琳]做什么？每个人都有非常深入的答案。基础设施。
Well first, if she has a better telephone link in her village, that is the first step to sell her products. If the roads are improved, again, a better way to sell the products.
好吧，如果她的村子有更好的电话链接，那是销售产品的第一步。如果道路得到改善，同样是销售产品的更好方式。
The health table tells us they're working on a plan for hospitals in her area. Education table? They're working on a plan for more free schools.
卫生小组告诉我们，他们正在为她所在的地区制定医院计划。教育小组呢？他们正在制定更多免费学校的计划。
At which point, a Trinidadian woman grabs my arm to tell me, kids need more than schools, you know? They need activities, dance classes, that we are offering over at this table.
这时，一位特立尼达女士抓住我的手臂告诉我，孩子们需要的不仅仅是学校，你知道吗？他们需要活动、舞蹈课，我们就在这张桌子提供这些。
And over at the environment table, they're offering canals.
而在环境桌旁，他们提供运河。
So you have-- right here in your grid-- millions of dollars for canals. That's exactly the thing that she wants. She wants a canal.
所以你的表格里就有数百万美元用于修建运河。这正是她想要的。她想要一条运河。
Yeah, so hopefully she'll get some. Hopefully.
是的，希望她能得到一些。希望吧。
Hopefully your computer will result in her getting a canal.
希望你的电脑最终能让她得到一条运河。
We are hoping so.
我们希望如此。
So the people in this room have their plans. And the world is going to spend billions of dollars on those plans. But now that we've seen how complicated it is to do something basic like get some crates into the hands of some mango farmers, it raises the question, what'll it take for all that money to do something? To actually result in canals and roads and electricity and crates actually getting to [? Jealin? ?]
所以在这个房间里的人有他们的计划。全世界将在这类计划上花费数十亿美元。但既然我们已经看到了像把箱子交到芒果农手中这样基本的事情有多复杂，这就提出了一个问题：所有这些钱要起到作用需要什么？要真正导致运河、道路、电力和箱子真正到达[杰琳]手中需要什么？
So, let's say you're the US government. You're committed-- as the US government is-- to spending lots of money rebuilding Haiti. You basically have two choices. Chana, the first please.
所以，假设你是美国政府。你承诺——正如美国政府所做的那样——花费大量资金重建海地。你基本上有两个选择。查娜，第一个请说。
Number one. You could hire Haitian companies and American companies do build things. The Haitian companies will be the Haitian elite. The American companies will leave after a year or two. And if you're Hilary Clinton, in a year-- the anniversary of the earthquake-- you can point to a bunch of successes, big ones. Hospitals rebuilt and roads that are way better than any Haiti has seen. If you're [? Jealin, ?] you probably still don't know how to pack your mangoes into crates and you probably aren't lucky enough to have your tiny piece of land chosen for a tiny canal either. So, Adam, let's look at number two.
第一，你可以雇佣海地公司和美国公司来建设。海地公司将是海地精英。美国公司一两年后就会离开。如果现在是希拉里·克林顿，一年后——地震周年纪念日——她可以指出一系列成功，重大的成功。医院重建了，道路比海地见过的任何道路都好得多。如果你是[杰琳]，你可能仍然不知道怎么把芒果装进箱子里，你可能也没有那么幸运，你的那一小块土地也不会被选中修一条小运河。所以，亚当，让我们看看第二个选择。
Number two, you do what development experts call capacity building. You teach the people of Haiti how to do all these things. You use this rebuilding process to give Haiti the ability to build itself. Which means, do for [? Jealin, ?] what America did for farmers more than 100 years ago, create a class of ag-extension agents who go to farms and figure out the best solution for each one, train farmers and laborers how to do things like build proper canals, create small banks to lend the money to farmers for this kind of investment, and you teach [? Jealin ?] how to pack her produce correctly, to wash it and to sell it directly to the exporter.
第二，做发展专家所说的“能力建设”。你教海地人民如何做所有这些事。你利用这个重建过程赋予海地自我建设的能力。这意味着，为[杰琳]做美国100多年前为农民做的事，创建一类农业推广人员，去到农场弄清楚每个人的最佳方案，培训农民和劳动者如何修建合适的运河，建立小型银行给农民提供此类投资的贷款，你教[杰琳]如何正确包装农产品，清洗它并直接卖给出口商。
This option, capacity building, do I even need to say it? It takes a long time and it's really, really hard. You need foreign money and you need Haitians to believe in the projects and to participate fully. And you need NGOs that are willing to stay for as long as it takes, which brings us to a classic problem with NGOs and foreign assistance.
这个选择，能力建设，我还需要说吗？这需要很长时间，而且真的、真的很难。你需要外国资金，你需要海地人相信这些项目并充分参与。你需要那些愿意尽可能长时间留下的非政府组织，这带出了非政府组织和外国援助的一个经典问题。
How you doing?
你好吗？
I'm OK. I had a long day. I had a very long day.
我很好。我度过了漫长的一天。非常漫长的一天。
Several months after the earthquake, we meet up with Jean-Maurice at his cousin's hotel, the same place where the world's experts gathered together to figure out how much it would cost to build Haiti out of poverty. The conference room has emptied out and Jean-Maurice-- Mango Man-- told us he got a call earlier in the week from MarChE, the NGO that was helping train [? Jealin ?] and the other farmers. USAID cut their funding. MarChE is closing their doors. Jean-Maurice shakes his head.
地震发生几个月后，我们在他表亲的酒店见到了让-莫里斯，就是全世界专家聚在一起计算重建海地所需资金的那个地方。会议室空了，让-莫里斯——“芒果男”——告诉我们，他本周早些时候接到MarChE的电话，就是那个帮助培训[杰琳]和其他农民的非政府组织。美国国际开发署削减了他们的资金。MarChE要关门了。让-莫里斯摇了摇头。
Again, that's the habit. It's the norm. They start something, they don't finish it. These NGOs, when they come on the field they make promises and they don't finish up and they don't deliver.
再次重申，那是习惯。那是常态。他们开始了一些事情，却没有完成。这些非政府组织来到实地时做出承诺，却不完成，也不交付。
This was confusing. There was just a major earthquake and everyone wants to help Haiti. People are sending money, texting money, and USAID is cancelling programs? I called USAID and our conversation with confusing too.
这很令人困惑。刚刚发生了大地震，每个人都想帮助海地。人们在汇款，发短信捐款，而美国国际开发署却在取消项目？我打电话给美国国际开发署，我们的谈话也很混乱。
We didn't decide to close any program.
我们并没有决定关闭任何项目。
This is Anthony Chan. He's deputy director for USAID in Haiti, and at first he tells me, technically, they're not closing the program. They're just letting its funding run out. Then he tells me that with all this new money after the earthquake, they need to reassess all their programs and think bigger than little ones like MarChE. And finally he tells me, OK, the program is going away, but it's not his fault.
这是安东尼·陈。他是美国国际开发署驻海地的副主任，起初他告诉我，技术上讲，他们没有关闭项目。他们只是让资金耗尽。然后他告诉我，地震后有了所有这些新资金，他们需要重新评估所有项目，并比MarChE这种小项目考虑得更远。最后他告诉我，好吧，项目确实要消失了，但这不是他的错。
I mean, it's not us deciding. We have bosses in Washington and they are the ones who make those decisions. I mean, eventually they're going to communicate that to us and we'll get the money and we'll begin to work in those areas. And the response to the farmers, we are not going away forever. We are going to be back. Maybe the partners are going to be different, but she shouldn't feel abandoned. The actors may change, but the movie and the plot will still go on.
我的意思是，不是我们决定的。华盛顿有我们的老板，是他们做的决定。我的意思是，最终他们会把这些传达给我们，我们会拿到钱，并在这些领域开始工作。对于农民的回应，我们不会永远离开。我们会回来的。也许合作伙伴会不同，但她不应该感到被遗弃。演员可能会改变，但电影和情节会继续。
That movie has been going on for more than half a century. There's this recent report called "Haiti in the Balance," which documents how time after time, USAID programs are started and then-- before they can actually help anyone-- a decision is made in Washington to send aid in a whole new direction.
那部电影已经上演了半个多世纪了。最近有一份叫《海地的平衡》的报告，记录了美国国际开发署的项目一次又一次启动，然后——在真正能帮助任何人之前——华盛顿做出了决定，将援助派向了全新的方向。
The two Marche staff we met left Haiti a couple of weeks ago. Mango season has opened without crates. And this, of course, is how you can continue to have 10,000 NGOs in a country that keeps getting poorer.
我们见到的两名Marche员工几周前离开了海地。芒果季在没有箱子的情况下开始了。而这，当然就是为什么你可以在一个不断变穷的国家继续拥有10,000个非政府组织的原因。
Chana Joffe-Walt and Adam Davidson are part of the Planet Money team. If you like this kind of story-- economics, but interesting. You can be getting it twice a week on the Planet Money podcast and at their blog, www.npr.org/money. It's a co-production between our program and NPR news.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特和亚当·戴维森是“星球货币”团队的一员。如果你喜欢这种故事——经济学，但很有趣。你可以在“星球货币”播客和他们的博客www.npr.org/money上每周收听两次。这是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。
Coming up, a new definition of atheist during an earthquake. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，地震中无神论者的新定义。那一刻马上到来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共电台，节目继续。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Island Time," stories about what happens next in Haiti, now that the world is flooding it with money and help. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act TWO, Compound Fracture.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“岛屿时间”，讲述在世界向海地倾注金钱和帮助之后，海地接下来会发生什么。我们到了节目的第二幕。第二幕：粉碎性骨折。
According to the US State Department, there are about 40,000 American citizens who live in Haiti year round. These are business people, NGOs, missionaries. In the 1980s and 1990s, Apricot Irving's family was among them. Apricot's parents were missionaries, agricultural missionaries. They did erosion control farming, reforestation projects. They lived in a town called Limbe, about 150 miles north of Port-au-Prince. It's been 20 years since her family left, but her parents still go back to the north of Haiti every couple of years. And in March, Apricot went with them to see how people are building a new Haiti and how different that effort is from when she was a kid.
据美国国务院称，大约有40,000名美国公民常年居住在海地。这些人是商人、非政府组织成员、传教士。在20世纪80年代和90年代，阿普里科特·欧文的家人就在其中。阿普里科特的父母是传教士，农业传教士。他们做侵蚀控制耕作、植树造林项目。他们住在距离太子港以北约150英里的林贝小镇。她家离开已经20年了，但她的父母每隔几年还会回到海地北部。3月，阿普里科特和他们一起去看看人们如何建设一个新的海地，以及那种努力与她小时候有何不同。
The missionary compound where I grew up-- that's what we called it, the compound-- is about 15 miles away from where Columbus sank the Santa Maria in 1492. Columbus was just the first of many foreigners with big dreams of how to improve Haiti. We heard a lot about Columbus growing up on the compound because Dr. Hodges-- who ran the missionary hospital in Limbe-- was a huge fan. When I was a teenager, the compound had everything we needed, a missionary school, a TV room, friends. But when I went back this time to visit, it was like a ghost town, a ghost town with a very loud generator.
我长大的传教士大院——我们就是这么叫它的，大院——距离哥伦布1492年沉没“圣玛丽亚号”的地方大约15英里。哥伦布只是众多怀揣着如何改善海地这种大梦想的外国人中的第一个。我们在大院里长大时听了很多关于哥伦布的故事，因为霍奇斯博士——他在林贝经营传教士医院——是他的超级粉丝。我十几岁的时候，大院里有我们需要的一切：传教士学校、电视室、朋友。但当我这次回来参观时，它就像一座鬼城，一座带着非常吵闹发电机的鬼城。
It is kind of creepy in here. There's nobody around. There's all these houses that used to be full of missionary families and kids running around and there's not really anybody else. There's Joanna. Hi Joanna, how are you?
这里有点阴森。周围没人。有这么多曾经挤满传教士家庭和到处跑的孩子们的房子，现在真的没有其他人了。乔安娜在那里。嗨，乔安娜，你好吗？
You look pretty good.
你看起来很不错。
You look pretty good too.
你也看起来很不错。
Travelling all over the world. Feel great as long as I don't walk.
游历世界各地。只要我不走路，感觉就很棒。
Dr. Hodges died 15 years ago, but his wife Joanna still spends a lot of time in Limbe. She's 87 years old and she's formidable. Everyone thought she'd retire in 2004 when three guys with guns broke into her house. She ended up chasing them down the driveway as they tried to steal her car. One guy broke her arm by beating her with a stick.
霍奇斯博士15年前去世了，但他的妻子乔安娜仍然在林贝花很多时间。她87岁了，而且很强大。2004年有三个持枪歹徒闯入她家时，每个人都以为她会退休。最后是她在他们试图偷车时追赶着他们穿过车道。其中一个人用棍子殴打她，打断了她的手臂。
The watchman later found that the thing that he'd hit me with, it was the walking stick that my husband used to use. But anyway, my arm is OK now. You can't even see the scar.
守卫后来发现他用来打我的东西，原来是我丈夫曾经使用的那根拐杖。但总之，我的手臂现在没事了。你连疤痕都看不见。
What did you tell the men when they came to your house?
歹徒闯入你家时你对他们说了什么？
I told them, if they killed me, that was all right. Because I knew that God would take care of me, and that I'd come to Haiti mainly to tell the Haitians about God. And I knew that he had a place for me. And I said, "Does he have a place for you?" Because I said, "I don't think he would want you to be doing what you're doing because it's not very nice." They said, "Shut her up," and they tied a cloth around my mouth. [LAUGHTER]
我告诉他们，如果他们杀了我，那也没关系。因为我知道上帝会照顾我，而且我来海地主要是为了告诉海地人关于上帝的事。我知道他为我留了位置。我说，“他为你们留了位置吗？”因为我说，“我不认为他会想让你们做你们现在做的事，因为那不太好。”他们说，“让她闭嘴，”然后用布蒙住了我的嘴。[笑声]
I can't believe she can laugh about this now. But maybe that's what spending 52 years in Haiti will do for you. I'm really fond of Joanna. I've known her since I was six years old and she's like a grandma to me. She epitomizes the old way of doing aid work, sort of 19th century benevolence. The foreigners-- usually whites-- lead the way, set an example, do whatever they can, and hope the Haitians catch on. In other words, the foreigners are always in charge. It sounds a little crazy, but until a few years ago, Joanna kept the keys to the medical supply storage room on a chain around her neck. When the Haitian doctors needed to perform an emergency surgery in the middle of the night, they had to wake her up. And, because she was in her 80s, carry her over the mud puddles to open it. The hospital is still run by Joanna's son, even though he now lives in Florida and hasn't been to Haiti in years.
真不敢相信她现在还能拿这件事开玩笑。但也许这就是在海地生活52年带给你的。我真的很喜欢乔安娜。我从六岁起就认识她了，她就像我的祖母一样。她是旧式援助工作的缩影，某种19世纪的仁慈。外国人——通常是白人——带头，树立榜样，尽他们所能，并希望海地人能跟上。换句话说，外国人总是负责人。这听起来有点疯狂，但直到几年前，乔安娜还把医疗用品储藏室的钥匙锁在挂在她脖子上的链子上。当海地医生需要在半夜进行紧急手术时，他们必须把她叫醒。而且，因为她80多岁了，还要把她扛过泥坑去开门。医院现在仍由乔安娜的儿子经营，尽管他现在住在佛罗里达，已经多年没去过海地了。
So with all the different aid organizations coming into Haiti right now to help out with earthquake relief, is there any advice that you would give to somebody who has never been to Haiti before?
所以，现在这么多不同的援助组织来到海地帮助救灾，对于从未去过海地的人，你有什么建议吗？
I would say that, don't try to change the Haitian people. Try to deal with him and try to understand them. And take them as you would other people. They're people and they need help. They look at life differently than we do. But that doesn't mean that they don't deserve help. Sometimes they're grateful and sometimes they're not.
我会说，不要试图改变海地人民。试着与他们打交道，并试着理解他们。像对待其他人一样对待他们。他们是人，他们需要帮助。他们看待生活的方式与我们不同。但这并不意味着他们不值得帮助。有时他们很感激，有时他们不感激。
Far fewer patients come to the hospital now than when I lived here for a few reasons. People really loved Dr. Hodges, and when he died, things changed. The hospital got rid of its old payment system, where you were offered credit if you couldn't pay right away. Instead, they started charging a fee upfront for a consultation. It's not much, about $1. But it was more than a lot of people could afford. People resented it. Things got ugly for a while. Graffiti, threats, some protests. Also, there's more competition than there used to be. The number of small Haitian run clinics have opened up that didn't exist 20 years ago. The hospital feels pretty empty right now. But these clinics are jammed with patients.
现在来医院的病人比我住在这里时少得多，原因有几个。人们真的很爱霍奇斯博士，而当他去世后，情况变了。医院取消了旧的支付系统，那时如果你不能马上付款，会提供信用赊账。相反，他们开始提前收取咨询费。虽然不多，大约1美元，但这比很多人能负担得起的要多。人们对此感到不满。情况有一段时间变糟了。涂鸦、威胁、一些抗议。此外，竞争也比过去多了。出现了更多海地人经营的诊所，20年前不存在。医院现在感觉很空。但这些诊所里挤满了病人。
This is Steve James, Dr. Steve James. I grew up with his kids at the missionary compound in Limbe. For a while, Steve was Medical Director at the hospital there, the Hodges Hospital. The work he's doing now is an attempt at something different, a totally different approach to development work.
这是史蒂夫·詹姆斯，史蒂夫·詹姆斯博士。我和他的孩子们在林贝的传教士大院一起长大。有一段时间，史蒂夫是那里的霍奇斯医院的医疗主任。他现在所做的工作是对某种不同的尝试，是一种完全不同的发展工作方法。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语]
He spends much of his morning greeting people and kissing them. This is how you start the day in Haiti. Everyone asks how your family is, how you slept last night. You can usually tell who the visiting Americans are, because they're the ones trying to skip the handshakes and get straight to work. But not Steve James. He's been in Haiti 30 years now. Every month, he visits 11 small Haitian clinics, including this one. All the clinics Steve visits are faith-based, community-run organizations, meaning the decisions are made by a board of locals. Steve is not on any of the boards. It's kind of a new state of affairs here. He's a white guy and he's not in charge of anything.
他大部分时间都在问候人们并亲吻他们。这就是在海地开始新一天的方式。每个人都会问你的家人怎么样，昨晚睡得怎么样。你通常能看出谁是来访的美国人，因为他们是那些试图跳过握手直奔工作的人。但史蒂夫·詹姆斯不是。他已经在海地工作30年了。每个月，他都会访问11家海地小诊所，包括这一家。史蒂夫访问的所有诊所都是基于信仰的、社区运营的组织，意味着决策是由当地人组成的委员会做出的。史蒂夫不在任何委员会里。这里出现了一种新常态。他是个白人，但他不负责任何事情。
Yeah, I'm not a program director. I don't run anything. I just stand by and ask questions and encourage, is all. And this is the business office.
是的，我不是项目主任。我不负责任何事情。我只是站在旁边提问并鼓励，仅此而已。这是办公室。
He shows me around Ebenezer clinic, which was five miles away from the old missionary hospital in Limbe. It's a small, two story building. But there are at least 100 people waiting to be seen, both inside the building and outside under a tree. The clinic has far fewer resources than the hospital. They don't have a surgery wing. They don't even have a place for patients to spend the night. But they let you pay what you can and give you credit for the rest. After the earthquake, they let everyone in for free, not just earthquake victims. Even though the clinic was already $8,500 in debt.
他带我参观了埃比尼泽诊所，距离林贝的老传教士医院五英里远。这是一栋两层的小楼。但至少有100人在等待看病，无论是楼里还是楼外树下。这家诊所的资源比医院少得多。他们没有手术室。甚至没有供病人过夜的地方。但他们让你量力而行，其余部分给予赊账。地震后，他们让每个人都免费看病，不仅是地震受害者。尽管诊所已经负债8,500美元了。
Ah, Dr. Manno, we are on the radio with the medical director.
啊，曼诺医生，我们正在和医疗主任通广播。
Hi.
嗨。
Good morning, Manno. How was Port-au-Prince?
早上好，曼诺。太子港怎么样？
A lot of work. A lot, a lot of work.
很多工作。非常、非常多的工作。
If anyone's in charge here it's Manno. He just got back from doing relief work in Port-au-Prince. Manno's a few years older than I am and I've known him since I was 14. Since I last saw him, Manno has become a doctor. He's the medical director for this clinic, though some patients still want to see the blonde, the foreigner with the American medical degree, the white guy. It happens while I'm standing there and it's awkward. A Haitian pastor comes in and asks for an appointment with Steve who's rushing to make another appointment, so he turns to Manno to see if he can do the consultation instead.
如果说这里有人负责的话，那就是曼诺。他刚从太子港做完救灾工作回来。曼诺比我大几岁，我14岁起就认识他了。自从上次见到他，曼诺已经成为了一名医生。他是这家诊所的医疗主任，尽管有些病人仍然想看那个金发外国人，那个拥有美国医学学位的、白人医生。这就在我站着的时候发生了，场面很尴尬。一位海地牧师走进来要求和史蒂夫预约，但他正忙着去赶另一个预约，所以他转向曼诺看能否改为他进行咨询。
He doesn't have his chart yet. So I don't know if you can see him for me, or--
他还没拿到挂号单。所以我不知道你能不能代我，或者——
When these people come they want to be seen by you.
这些人来的时候想让你看。
I know, I'm sorry.
我知道，我很抱歉。
Ask him to go home and come when you are here?
叫他回家，等你在这里的时候再来？
Well, that's the problem. I told him today I would be here.
嗯，这就是问题所在。我今天告诉他我会在这里的。
Say you are not afraid of, but he has to come back on Monday because--
说你不是怕，但他必须周一再来，因为——
You can hear the frustration in Manno's voice. Because of course, this has happened before. It makes Steve uncomfortable.
你可以听到曼诺声音里的挫败感。因为当然，这种情况以前发生过。这让史蒂夫很不舒服。
I will tell him that I have two doctors better than me, and he can see them. Oh here we go, Bonjour, Bonjour. The baby just came.
我会告诉他我有两位比我更好的医生，他可以看他们。噢，这里有，你好，你好。宝宝刚来。
A few days before I arrived, Manno had come back to town with a family of earthquake refugees in the back of his truck, including this three-month-old, who Steve's been waiting to see. Her arm looks terrible. It hangs at a strange angle from her elbow. She comes in with her aunt and her aunt's sister-in-law.
我到达的前几天，曼诺带回了一家地震难民，坐在他的卡车后座，包括这个三个月大的宝宝，史蒂夫一直在等她。她的手臂看起来很糟糕。它从肘部以奇怪的角度悬挂着。她跟着姑姑和姑姑的嫂子一起来的。
They said the baby's got diarrhea and they're worried that the baby's dehydrated today. That's a pretty little baby, baby girl. Her name is-- she has an unusual name. It's Quincy [SPEAKING FRENCH] Kaira. Jacque is her last name.
他们说宝宝拉肚子，他们很担心宝宝今天脱水了。那是很漂亮的小宝宝，女婴。她的名字是——她有个不寻常的名字。叫昆西[法语]凯拉。杰克是她的姓。
She was a month old when the earthquake hit and she was trapped under the rebel for two days. Neighbors could hear a baby crying. What they didn't realize-- until they dug her out-- was that she was cradled in the arms of her dead mother. Steve thinks she might have survived by nursing. The women have brought an X-ray of her arm, taken at another rural clinic Steve had sent them to, because Ebenezer doesn't have an X-ray machine.
地震发生时她才一个月大，被困在瓦砾下两天。邻居们能听到宝宝哭声。直到挖出她才意识到——她是蜷缩在她死去的母亲怀里。史蒂夫认为她可能是靠喝母乳活下来的。妇女们带了一张她手臂的X光片，是在史蒂夫送她们去的另一家农村诊所拍的，因为埃比尼泽没有X光机。
OK, we don't yet have electricity in the clinic. They haven't turned on the generator yet, so--
好吧，我们的诊所还没有电。他们还没打开发电机，所以——
So in a clinic like this, what do you use electricity for?
在这样的诊所里，你把电用在什么地方？
Well, for one, right now I need it to look at this X-ray. That would be nice. Otherwise, I have to hold it up to the window here and make my best guess on a window X-ray.
嗯，其中一点，现在我需要它看这张X光片。那会很不错。不然，我只能把它对着窗户，在窗户的光线下凭感觉猜测。
The X-ray isn't the exact angle he'd asked the technician for. So he can't really tell if the elbow's fractured or dislocated, though he suspects both. Steve wants to send the baby to another clinic-- an hour and a half away-- to see one of the visiting orthopedic surgeons-- an American who came to help out with earthquake relief. He makes sure to consult with Manno first.
X光片不是他要求的确切角度。所以他无法确定肘部是骨折还是脱位，尽管他怀疑两者都有。史蒂夫想把宝宝送到另一家诊所——一个半小时路程外——去看一位来帮忙地震救灾的访问骨科医生。他确保先咨询曼诺。
What I would like to know is whether-- at this age-- you would want to intervene or you would want to just wait for the baby to be older. Or, I just would like some help on that.
我想知道的是——在这个年龄——你是想干预，还是想等宝宝再大一点。或者，我只是想在这个问题上得到一点帮助。
I guess the best is to have the opinion of the orthopedics.
我想最好听听骨科医生的意见。
If Steve had still been director of the hospital in the compound, he could have had everything done at the same place, X-rays, surgery, an overnight room. Instead, he has to send the baby to three different places-- over horrendous roads-- and someone has to pay for all that. It makes you understand why a lot of NGOs still operate the old foreigners in charge way, it's efficient. This way, the opposite of efficient. But what Steve's doing is that term you heard earlier in the show, capacity building, even though Steve would never call it that. He calls it, "building community." If you want Haitians to create and sustain their own institutions, this is what it looks like, slow and sometimes cumbersome.
如果史蒂夫还是大院医院的主任，他可以在同一个地方做完所有事：X光、手术、过夜房。相反，他必须把宝宝送到三个不同的地方——走可怕的道路——而且还得有人支付所有这些费用。这让你明白为什么很多非政府组织仍然以旧的那种“外国人负责”的方式运作，它很高效。这种方式，与高效完全相反。但史蒂夫所做的是你之前在节目中听到的那个术语：能力建设，尽管史蒂夫从不这样称呼它。他称之为“建设社区”。如果你想让海地人创造并维持他们自己的机构，这就是它看起来的样子，缓慢而有时繁琐。
But Steve knows the pitfalls of the other model. When he was in charge of the old missionary hospital, he found the job so stressful that he even considered leaving medicine. He came to a kind of crossroads and had to make a hard choice. We talked about it in the car.
但史蒂夫知道这种模式的陷阱。当他是传教士医院的老主任时，他发现这份工作压力很大，甚至考虑离开医学界。他来到了某种十字路口，必须做出艰难的选择。我们在车里谈到了这一点。
The choice really is-- it almost became for me-- an either/or. On the one hand was that in the face of dysfunction, and in the face of extreme human need, what was required of me was to build a citadel, to become a dictator. And in that dictatorship-- benevolent dictatorship-- I could be the cowboy to fix the problems that would bring efficiency, service and security. What's wrong with that? Why not become a benevolent dictator? The problem that I found with that, is that model creates, in a way, a new slave plantation mentality, where the slaves become dependent on the slave masters. And in the end, one reaps the fruit of slavery, discontent, anger, violence. The choice to then go the other extreme, to purposely work hard at not becoming a dictator-- for the sake of building community-- means that people are going to suffer. People are going to die. Goods will not be provided. Services will not be rendered. Here we are praying when there's somebody that needs a C-section and we can't get it for her. There's a terrible choice.
选择实际上变成了二选一。一方面，在功能失调和极端人类需求面前，我被要求建立一个城堡，成为独裁者。在那种独裁中——仁慈的独裁——我可以成为修复问题的牛仔，带来效率、服务和安全。那有什么问题？为什么不成为仁慈的独裁者？我发现那个模式的问题是，它以一种方式创造了一种新的奴隶种植园心态，奴隶变得依赖奴隶主。最终，人们收获的是奴隶制的果实：不满、愤怒、暴力。选择另一个极端，即为了建设社区而努力不成为独裁者——意味着人们将会受苦。人们将会死去。物资不会提供。服务不会提供。这里我们正在祈祷，而有人需要剖腹产，我们却做不到。这是一个可怕的选择。
And why is it that, in choosing community, there are these added costs? Why do people die? Why are the goods not distributed?
为什么选择社区会带来这些额外的代价？为什么人们会死？为什么物资没有分配？
Because community takes time, perseverance and relationship building. Yeah, it drives Americans crazy. We're a fix it culture. That's the height of evil probably, from an American cultural point of view, is to not fix a problem when it's right there to fix. And what's the problem? Fix it.
因为社区需要时间、毅力和关系建设。是的，这让美国人抓狂。我们是一种“修复它”的文化。从美国文化的角度来看，这是最高级的恶，就是当一个问题就在那里需要修复时，却不去修复。问题是什么？修复它。
The good news-- Steve says-- is that the slow, cumbersome process is working. There's progress. These clinics are surviving basically on their own, supporting themselves with very little outside help. And when the earthquake hit, that progress paid off. It was Haitians who were on the scene first-- doctors like Manno-- pulling people out of the rubble, distributing water, days before the foreign aid organizations arrived.
史蒂夫说，好消息是，缓慢、繁琐的过程正在奏效。有进展。这些诊所基本上靠自己生存，几乎没有任何外部帮助就支撑着自己。当地震发生时，这种进展得到了回报。最先出现在现场的是海地人——像曼诺这样的医生——在外国援助组织到达前几天，从瓦砾中救人，分发水。
Apricot Irving. She's writing a book about growing up on a missionary compound in Haiti. Right now she's looking for a publisher.
阿普里科特·欧文。她正在写一本关于在海地传教士大院成长的书。目前她正在寻找出版商。
Act Three, "Hait is Destiny." Ben Fountain is a fiction writer who has been going to Haiti two or three times a year for 20 years. He has close friends there. He's written short stories set there, based on the things he's seen. He returned in March to catch up with people.
第三幕，“海地是命运。”本·方丹是一位小说家，20年来每年去海地两三次。他在那里有亲密的朋友。他写过以那里为背景的短篇小说，基于他所见的事情。他在3月回到那里与人们叙旧。
"Did you think we were dead?" This was the first thing asked me by the 13-year-old daughter of my friend Gary, when I reached them by phone a few days after the quake. "Did you think we were dead? She said, as soon as she came on the line. And I hesitated, it seemed rude just to say to a child, "Yes, I thought you were dead." But there was a firmness in her voice, a focus and calm that showed she was beyond all the finer points of etiquette. For the past several days, she'd been very possibly dead to her family and friends back in the states. And now she was testing it, probing this other reality, the one where she died on January 12. How would it feel to be dead? What would it mean to exist only in old emails, pictures, the minds of others?
“你以为我们死了吗？”这是我朋友加里的13岁女儿在我地震后几天通过电话联系上他们时问我的第一件事。“你以为我们死了吗？”她一上线就说。我犹豫了一下，对一个孩子直说“是的，我以为你们死了”似乎很不礼貌。但她的声音里有一种坚定、专注和平静，表明她已经超越了所有礼仪的细枝末节。过去几天，她对家乡的家人和朋友来说可能已经死了。现在她在测试，探测这种另一种现实，即她在1月12日死去的现实。死了是什么感觉？只存在于旧邮件、照片、他人脑海中意味着什么？
Then the phone was passed to her brother, and he wanted to know too. "Did you think we were dead?" But they hadn't died. Their house had held and they'd ridden out the quake jammed in a doorway with their parents and uncle, the five of them lurching and pitching in that tight space like shipwrecked survivors tossed in a storm. But from their front yard, you could look across the neighboring ravine at the remains of 100 houses that hadn't held.
然后电话被传给了她的哥哥，他也想知道。“你以为我们死了吗？”但他们没死。他们的房子没倒，他们和父母及叔叔挤在门口撑过了地震，五个人像在风暴中被抛来抛去的沉船幸存者一样在那个狭窄的空间里踉跄倾斜。但从他们的前院，你可以望向邻近的沟壑，看到100座没撑住的房子的残骸。
It's like a lobotomy, seeing destruction on this scale. Not just the outsize scale, but the mind-numbing density within the scale. The sheer sensory overload of detail and texture. That football field-sized wilderness of junk and rubble that used to be a trade school, you could find entire geographies of ruin within that expanse. Hills, butes, hummocks, valleys and craters, broad flats cut through with twisting gullies, shredded clothes, shoes, papers, mangled furniture, dark oily clumps of decomposing human matter, rebar twisted and raveled like giant spaghetti balls. And then something impossible and ridiculous, an easy chair, a thickly upholstered loveseat, perched at the top of a free-standing spiral staircase that spun off into nowhere. It didn't make sense. Port-au-Prince was making me stupid.
看到这种程度的破坏就像被做了脑叶切除术。不仅仅是超大的规模，而且是在规模中令人麻木的密度。细节和质感的纯粹感官过载。那片曾经是职业学校的足球场大小的垃圾和瓦砾荒地，你可以在那片广袤中找到整个废墟的地理景观。山丘、孤峰、土堆、山谷和陨石坑，宽阔的平原被蜿蜒的冲沟切开，粉碎的衣服、鞋子、纸张、被毁坏的家具、腐烂的人体组织的深色油腻团块、像巨大的意大利面球一样扭曲和缠绕的钢筋。然后是某种不可能和荒谬的东西：一把扶手椅，一张厚实软垫的沙发，栖息在一座延伸到虚无中的独立螺旋楼梯顶端。这说不通。太子港让我变笨了。
"I have a new definition of the word atheist," my friend, a Haitian eye doctor, told me. "This is the person who doesn't cry out to God in the middle of an earthquake." My friend, the eye doctor, comes from one of the old Mulatto families. And he may be the one true genius I've known in my life. He's fluent in six languages and proficient in three more, knows long passages of world literature by heart, plays the piano beautifully, and placed third in the Haitian National Chess Championship when he was 12.
“我对‘无神论者’这个词有了新的定义，”我的朋友，一位海地眼科医生告诉我。“这就是在地震中不向神呼救的人。”我的朋友，那位眼科医生，来自旧穆拉托家族之一。他可能是我一生中认识的最真正的天才。他精通六种语言，另外三种也很熟练，熟记世界文学的长篇段落，钢琴弹得很好，12岁时在海地全国国际象棋锦标赛中获得第三名。
I met him almost 20 years ago, when he was a handsome, young doctor with jet black hair down to his shoulders and the slightly mad eyes of a Rasputin or Houdini. He was brilliant and knew it. On finding out he was a doctor, I made some trite comment about all the good he must be doing in his work.
我几乎20年前遇见他时，他是一个英俊的年轻医生，留着垂到肩膀的乌黑长发，有着像拉斯普廷或胡迪尼那样略显疯狂的眼睛。他很有才华，而且知道这一点。发现他是医生后，我就他工作中一定做的所有好事发表了一些陈腐的评论。
"No," he answered brusquely. "On the contrary, in Haiti, I'm like a jet pilot without a plane." I went to see him as soon as I arrived in Port-au-Prince and found him living with his family in their backyard. Most of their two story house was still standing, though the west wall had sheared away entirely, leaving that side of the house open to the air. And what remained was too shaky for habitation. So now they were living outdoors, sleeping in tents and a re-purposed tool shed and cooking on the stove they'd dragged outside.
“不，”他唐突地回答。“相反，在海地，我就像一个没有飞机的喷气式飞行员。”我一到太子港就去看他，发现他和家人住在他们的后院。他们两层楼的大房子大部分仍然屹立，尽管西墙完全被剪断，使房子的那一侧完全暴露在空气中。剩下的部分太不稳定，无法居住。所以现在他们住在户外，睡在帐篷和一个重新利用的工具棚里，用搬到外面的炉子做饭。
"And this is luxury," the doctor exclaimed, "We're the lucky ones." He and his wife and one of their sons had been on their small front gallery when the earthquake struck. And at first, they thought it was a heavy truck going by, some gargantuan piece of construction equipment. And then they told me something I would hear many times in the coming days, "We thought it was the apocalypse or Armageddon. We thought the world was blowing up. We thought this was the end of everything, so we just stood on the gallery hugging one another and waited for it to finish."
“这就是奢侈，”医生惊呼，“我们是幸运的。”地震发生时，他和他的妻子以及一个儿子正在他们小的前廊上。起初，他们以为是一辆重型卡车经过，某种巨大的建筑设备。然后他们告诉我我在接下来的几天里会听到很多次的事情：“我们以为是启示录或哈米吉多顿。我们以为世界正在爆炸。我们以为这就是一切的终结，所以我们只是站在廊上拥抱在一起，等待它结束。”
Such were expectations in Haiti, where the apocalypse comes more readily to mind than anything so far-fetched as an earthquake. A Danish filmmaker, a long time acquaintance of mine, was on the third floor of his house in Jacmel when the quake started. And he simply couldn't process what his eyes were seeing. The room started shaking. And then the walls started rippling and bending. And he wondered, how can the walls be moving like that? And there was a hole in the wall, and he wondered why there was a hole in the wall. And then the balcony was gone, and how could that be? He sat on his bed, watching it all unfold in slow motion, but his brain wouldn't accept the information. I asked him, did you think you were losing your mind?
这就是海地的期望，启示录比地震这种遥不可及的事情更容易想到。一位丹麦电影制片人，我的老相识，地震开始时正在他位于雅克梅勒房子的三楼。他根本无法处理他的眼睛所看到的。房间开始摇晃。然后墙壁开始起伏和弯曲。他想，墙壁怎么会那样动？墙上有一个洞，他想知道为什么墙上有一个洞。然后阳台没了，这怎么可能？他坐在床上，看着这一切缓慢发生，但他的大脑无法接受这些信息。我问他，你以为你在失去理智吗？
"Yes," he cried, "I did think I was losing my mind, because these things I was seeing just didn't make sense."
“是的，”他大喊，“我确实以为我在失去理智，因为我所看到的这些事情根本说不通。”
"You think the one thing that's certain in your life," the eye doctor told me, "Is the ground beneath your feet. You think this one thing at least is solid. And when that starts to shake, you experience real terror."
“你以为你生活中唯一确定的事情，”医生告诉我，“就是你脚下的土地。你以为至少这一件事是坚固的。而当它开始摇晃时，你就会体验到真正的恐惧。”
We sat down at the small kitchen table in their backyard. So how were they doing? "We're surviving," the doctor said with a shrug, though this might not seem so obvious. Their teen-aged sons hadn't had a school to go to since January 12. The wife's video rental business was lost in the quake. The doctor was doing a lot of meetings these days, but he said they were starting to make him feel like a character in a Kafka story. As one of only 50 ophthalmologists in the entire country, he was much in demand by foreign governments and NGOs to consult on health care projects. And after two solid months of meetings, he was going a little crazy.
我们坐在他们后院的小餐桌旁。他们过得怎么样？“我们正在生存，”医生耸耸肩说，尽管这看起来并不那么明显。自1月12日以来，他们的十几岁儿子就没有学校可上。妻子的录像带租赁业务在地震中损失了。医生最近做了很多会议，但他说他们开始让他感觉自己像是卡夫卡故事里的一个角色。作为全国仅有的50名眼科医生之一，外国政府和非政府组织对他咨询医疗保健项目的需求很大。在连续开了两个月会议后，他有点疯了。
"What happens at these meetings," he said, "Is that they meet to agree to evaluate the situation, so they can meet to agree to evaluate the situation, so they can meet to agree to evaluate and on and on." He'd been at one such meeting that very afternoon. "I told them it was all bull[BLEEP] and bluff. But even when I insult them, they don't listen to me. They just want a couple of Haitians at the table for decoration. We're there so they can keep on getting their money.
“这些会议上发生的是，”他说，“他们见面同意评估情况，这样他们就可以见面同意评估情况，这样他们就可以见面同意评估，如此往复。”那天下午他刚参加过这样的会议。“我告诉他们这全是胡扯和虚张声势。但即使我侮辱他们，他们也不听我的。他们只是想让几个海地人坐在桌旁作为装饰。我们在那里是为了让他们能继续拿到钱。
"On the plus side," he continued, "There was always plenty of food at these meetings," so he rarely needed to eat at home, which was good because he wasn't making any money these days. His office had been destroyed in the quake and the few pieces of equipment he'd managed to salvage sat in a forlorn little pile in his living room. These days, his practice consisted of people randomly dropping by his house. Doc, everything's all blurry. Doc, my eyes hurt. Doc, can you find me some glasses? I lost my glasses in the quake.
“从好的一面看，”他继续说，“这些会议上总是有足够的食物，”所以他很少需要在家吃饭，这很好，因为他最近没赚到钱。他的办公室在地震中被毁了，他设法抢救出来的几件设备堆在客厅里，显得孤零零的。这些天，他的诊所就是人们随机顺道来他家。医生，一切都很模糊。医生，我的眼睛痛。医生，你能帮我找副眼镜吗？我在地震中丢了眼镜。
Several days a week, he hitch a ride out to one of the tent camps and treat people for free. But otherwise, he sat in his backyard studying Chinese and reading the classics of western philosophy.
每周有几天，他搭车去一个难民营免费为人们治疗。但在其他时候，他坐在后院学习中文，阅读西方哲学经典。
"You know what I've noticed," he told me that first evening at his house, "God gives you 205 years to do something with Haiti and if you fail, he passes it on to someone else. The Spanish had it from 1492 to 1697, 205 years. Then the French from 1698 to 1803, 205 years. Then the Haitians, from 1804 to 2009, 205 years." So what was coming next? "Maybe a revolution," he answered cryptically. "Or maybe Haiti would survive as a sprawling industrial park for the international aid complex. Or maybe it would become a satellite of the United States, a kind of protectorate."
“你知道我注意到了什么吗？”他在他家的第一个晚上告诉我，“上帝给了你205年时间来处理海地问题，如果你失败了，他就把它传给别人。西班牙人从1492年到1697年拥有它，205年。然后是法国人从1698年到1803年，205年。然后是海地人，从1804年到2009年，205年。”那么接下来会发生什么？“也许是一场革命，”他隐晦地回答。“或者海地可能作为国际援助综合体的庞大工业园区生存下来。或者它可能成为美国的卫星，一种保护国。”
And then I brought up the subject of art. The doctor is-- among his many other talents and accomplishments-- an astute critic and tireless promoter of Haitian art. When I asked him whether anything had been rescued from the iconic institutions of Haitian art, the National Gallery, the Centre d'Art, or the murals of the Trinity Episcopal Church, his brow drew down and he brooded for a minute.
然后我提到了艺术话题。医生——在他众多其他天赋和成就中——是一位敏锐的评论家和海地艺术的孜孜不倦的推动者。当我问他是否有任何东西从海地艺术的标志性机构、国家美术馆、艺术中心或三一圣公会教堂的壁画中获救时，他眉头紧锁，沉思了一会儿。
"Art is finished in Haiti," he said abruptly, "After what happened here, art has nothing more to say to us." And he went on, "The philosopher Hegel said that before the end of time there will be the end of history, and before the end of history there will be the end of art, maybe this is what we're seeing here, the enacting of Hegel's theory. Haiti is leading the rest of the world to the end of time."
“海地的艺术完了，”他突然说，“在这里发生的事情之后，艺术没什么可对我们说的了。”他继续说，“哲学家黑格尔说，在时间终结之前会有历史的终结，在历史终结之前会有艺术的终结，也许这就是我们在这里看到的，黑格尔理论的演练。海地正在引领世界其他地方走向时间的终结。”
Riding around Port-au-Prince during the day, seeing the sheer biblical scale of the destruction, this could definitely put you in an apocalyptic frame of mind. "Poor Haiti," people say, "So primitive, so backward, so far behind the times." I've been hearing about how backward Haiti is for as long as I've been going. But how about this, what if Haiti is ahead of the times? It seems to be on the leading edge of so many current trends, environmental degradation, serial ecological disasters, crumbling infrastructure, a population that exceeds resources, plus a skewed economic order that channels vast wealth to a privileged few while the great majority of people stagnate and struggle. By any objective measure, Haiti appears well-advanced on the track that the rest of the world seems hell bent on following.
白天在太子港到处走走，看到纯粹的圣经规模的破坏，这绝对会让你陷入启示录般的心态。“可怜的海地，”人们说，“太原始，太落后，太跟不上时代。”只要我一直在去，我就一直在听说海地有多落后。但这个怎么样：如果海地领先于时代呢？它似乎处于这么多当前趋势的最前沿：环境退化、系列生态灾难、支离破碎的基础设施、人口超过资源，加上将巨额财富输送给少数特权阶层，而绝大多数人停滞不前、苦苦挣扎的倾斜经济秩序。从任何客观标准来看，海地似乎在世界其他地方一心想跟随的轨道上走得很靠前。
The eye doctor proposed yet another alternative for Haiti's feature which was the extinction of the Haitian people. In other words, no future at all. And why not? Many countries, many peoples have disappeared over the course of history. Why should Haiti be any different? From a sheer numbers standpoint, the earthquake had been a strong push in that direction. And now, he pointed to the mountains looming over Port-au-Prince. Every year there were fewer trees up there. Every year the rains loosened the soil a little more. Unless drastic changes were made, it was only a matter of time before the mountains crashed down in a kind of land tsunami and buried the city whole like a modern day Pompeii, only with mud and rock instead of volcanic ash.
眼科医生提出了海地特色的另一个选择，那就是海地人民的灭绝。换句话说，根本没有未来。为什么不呢？许多国家、许多民族在历史进程中消失了。为什么海地会有所不同？从纯粹的数字角度来看，地震向那个方向强力推了一把。现在，他指向笼罩在太子港上空的山脉。那里每年树木都在减少。每年雨水都会进一步松动土壤。除非做出彻底的改变，否则山脉在一场土地海啸中崩塌，像现代庞贝城一样把整个城市掩埋，只不过是泥土和岩石而不是火山灰，只是时间问题。
"The terrible thing about existence," the eye doctor told me a few days later, "Is not that there is suffering, but that there's no limit to suffering. I think there's going to be an explosion," the doctor confided, a sentiment that was echoed many times by many people over the course of my visit. Even Haitians, as resourceful and tough as they are, have their limits. They were watching in the camps. They were waiting.
“关于存在，可怕的事情，”几天后眼科医生告诉我，“不是有苦难，而是苦难没有限度。我想会有一次爆发，”医生私下说，这个情绪在我的访问过程中被许多人多次回应。即使海地人像他们一样足智多谋和坚韧，也有他们的限度。他们在那片营地看着。他们在等待。
[FRENCH PHRASE] was a line of graffiti you saw everywhere. [FRENCH PHRASE]. We're tired, we've had enough. We're simply, [FRENCH PHRASE]. We're here. That was what people often said when you asked how they were doing. [FRENCH PHRASE] we're here. Or a sassier variation, [FRENCH PHRASE]. Better that we're ugly and here than not here.
[法语短语]是你随处可见的涂鸦行。 [法语短语]。我们累了，我们受够了。我们简单地[法语短语]。我们在这里。当你问他们过得怎么样时，人们经常说。 [法语短语]我们在这里。或者更俏皮的变化，[法语短语]。在这里变丑总比不在要好。
All those tents in Port-au-Prince, all those thousands of tents, sometimes I'd look at them and imagine an army was massed out there. The last time I talked to my friend Gary, the one whose children had wanted to know if I'd thought they were dead, he told me a barricade had been erected outside the gate of the warehouse where he works. Gary is a logistics manager for one of the big NGOs, and those his warehouse operation was clearly there to do good, people were protesting, they wanted jobs. Gary had hired all the workers he could, but for the people outside it wasn't enough. For two days running, he'd had to negotiate his way through the barricade to get home. It's getting radical, he told me. And then he added, come back soon.
太子港所有的那些帐篷，所有那成千上万的帐篷，有时我会看着它们，想象一支军队在那里聚集。我最后一次和我的朋友加里交谈时，他那已经想知道我是否以为他们死了的孩子，他告诉我他的仓库大门外架起了一道障碍物。加里是大型非政府组织之一的物流经理，虽然他的仓库运营显然是为了做好事，但人们在抗议，他们想要工作。加里雇佣了他能雇佣的所有工人，但对外面的那些人来说这还不够。连续两天，他不得不通过障碍物协商回家。它正在变得激进，他告诉我。然后他补充说，快回来。
Ben Fountain. A few of the short stories that he's written, set in Haiti, are in his collection, brief encounters with Che Guevara.
本·方丹。他写的一些以海地为背景的短篇小说在文集《与切·格瓦拉的简短邂逅》中。
[MUSIC- "EXHIBIT H" BY JOELL ORTIZ]
[音乐- 乔尔·奥尔蒂斯的“Exhibit H”]
Our program today was produced by our senior producer, Julie Snyder with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollack, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Brian Reed, Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager.
我们今天的节目由我们的高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同制作。制作协助来自布莱恩·里德，塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米莉·康登是我们的办公室经理。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program, by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, oh we have complained, do we have to wear these silly This American Life blazers to work every single day? Can't we stop that? But he just replies,
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。芝加哥WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督，由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责。噢，我们抱怨过，我们必须每天穿着这些傻乎乎的《美国生活》西装外套上班吗？我们不能停止吗？但他只是回答，
I mean, it's not us deciding. We have bosses in Washington and they are the ones who make those decisions.
我的意思是，不是我们决定的。华盛顿有我们的老板，是他们做的决定。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI——国际公共电台。